بين جوانب قريه بيبان في مدينه نينوى
الاثريه العراقيه من الداخل شواهد الجدران
زينت برسمات فنان تدعو الى احياء التراث
الايزيدي وتزيين مدينته جدران زينتها ريشه
رسام
تهدف في تفاصيلها الى تعريف الاجيال
الجديده بتاريخ المدينه لا نسيانه والمرور
منه
هناء الساحه الرئيسيه للقريه وبين جدرانها
زينت رسمات اثريه وهي ساحه تقام بها
الاحتفالات الدينيه وحفلات الزفاف لاهالي
القريه
ريشه الفنان العراقي فارس بيباني الذي
يقضي الجهد والوقت لايصال رسائله للاجيال
القادمه
[موسيقى]
ووو اللي بالزمننا واللي بعمرنا احنا شفنا
ااا
هوايه امور قديمه يعني يعني لحقنا عليه بس
اكو شباب ما بسمعوا بس يشوفون بالصور
في الغايه حتى ممكن ترسم يجون شباب ارسم
واشرح لهم قبلكم
الفنان العراقي فارس بيباني
الحرب عينتها الامم المتحده بانها اباده
جماعيه ضد الايزيديين الذين ارتكب تنظيم
داعش في الثالث من اغسطس عام 2014
ويعود اصل الايزيديين الى مجتمع ديني يضم
400 الف شخص في شمال العراق
قبل ان يتعرضوا لحمله اباده قادها عناصر
داعش